buenos días para muchos peruanos el de
anoche ha sido quizás el más flojo de
los debates en la historia del país se
sintió que tanto el pedro castillo y
keiko fujimori repitieron lo mismo que
habían venido diciendo en sus mítines de
campaña y entrevistas al paso muchos
peruanos sintieron que más allá de las
propuestas las promesas faltó el como
cómo van a hacer para ejecutar estos
planes una vez que lleguen a un eventual
gobierno le faltó la definición y se
sintió también que keiko fujimori quien
tiene más experiencia en debates pues es
la tercera vez que compite por una
elección presidencial no supo derrotar a
casilla y éste sólo se dedicó a devolver
los ataques de la derecha fujimorista y
negar un supuesto vínculo con el
comunismo porque se habla de un empate
técnico en las encuestas de esta segunda
vuelta electoral francisco
se habla de un empate técnico porque las
encuestadoras mencionan que ambos
candidatos solamente tienen un margen de
diferencia a una diferencia que es mucho
menor al margen de error de las
encuestadoras
precisamente ipsos le otorga casi un 50
y 1.1 por ciento y a fujimori un 48.9
por ciento en las preferencias mientras
que iu o pe le otorga a castillo el 40.3
por ciento y fujimori el 38.3 por ciento
mucho de esto se va a deslumbrar el día
en que se realicen las elecciones pero
ahí se va a ver que la polarización en
que se encuentra actualmente el país no
va a parar porque va a continuar un
sector de la población que no quiere a
keiko fujimori como presidenta de los
peruanos ni a pedro casi o como jefe de
estado muchísimas gracias
francisco